>>All right, [INDISTINCT]
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Are you ready?
>> ERICKSON: All right. All right, my name
is Tyler Erickson, and I'm a research scientist
at Michigan Tech Research Institute in Ann
Arbor, Michigan. And today, I'll be talking
about building visualizations of environmental
data, particularly space-time data, and also
about how to build data systems that can officially
generate complex KML that can display that
type of spatial and temporal data. The Earth
is a pretty complex place. There's processes
that happen in space and time and are quite
variable. And the representations of them
are always in the geospatial world who don't
necessarily convey the amount of complexity
that--that is really actually going on in
natural world. But when people actually see
a visualization, some type of time series
like a movie or something like that, they
can get a better understanding of what is
going on. But, unfortunately, for many of
these visualizations, like a video like this,
there's no kind of interactive aspect. And
that's one of the things I've seen as really
good about the virtual globe type of technology
that you can actually embed spatial and temporal
data into a virtual involved environment that
allows users to actually touch the data and
play with it, you know, navigate, turn on
and turn off different layers, and actually
navigate the space and time to actually have
more of the interactive learning experience
with the dataset. So today I'm going to talk
about one particular spatial temporal dataset
and it is model output that has to do with
global climate change. And so--to just to
give a quick overview of a rather complex
subject, I'm going to go over the 90 second
version of global climate change. All right.
To provide--let see--the land surface, oceans,
atmosphere, and subsurface are all carbon
reservoirs. Carbon in the atmosphere exists
as carbon dioxide, a green house gas. And
increases in green house gas concentrations
contribute to the warming of the Earth's surface.
What has changed in modern times is that the
humans had become very good at transferring
carbon from deep underground to the atmosphere
via the burning of fossil fuels. This activity
has caused carbon dioxide concentrations in
the atmosphere to steadily increase. These
two plots show the trend in carbon dioxide
concentrations measured over the last three
decades at various locations around the globe.
The animated plot on the left shows carbon
dioxide concentrations as a function of latitude
with the South Pole on the left and the North
Pole on the right. And the plot on the right
shows the temporal progression of these two
long term monitoring stations: one in Mauna
Loa in Hawaii and one at the South Pole. The
time series show consistently increasing levels
of carbon dioxide with the seasonal cycle
which is particularly strong for measurement
stations in the Northern Hemisphere. So to
quote some numbers, human activity is releasing
about 8 gigatons of carbon per year into the
atmosphere. About half of this remains there,
causing the massive carbon in the atmosphere
to increase at the rate of around 4 gigatons
per year. The remaining carbon is taken up
by the oceans and the land surface. However,
it's difficult to determine exactly when and
where the carbon goes because the additional
amount is small relative to the gross exchange
between the reservoirs and the exchange can
be highly variable in space and time. Understanding
where this carbon dioxide goes and the spatial
and temporal variability of processes that
control it is critical for accurately predicting
future climate change. Will the land and oceans
continue to absorb a large part of the excess
CO2 regenerate or will these processes stop
or reverse leaving to even higher rates of
global warming? Any questions? So if you knew,
there's a little conference that's going on
right now in Copenhagen where they're trying
to nail out some of these issues, kind of
a plan for what we're going to do in the future,
trying to get political leaders, business
leaders all in the same place to agree on
how to address the release of carbon into
the atmosphere and how that causes global
warming. It's really hard to get people to
agree to cuts in emissions because that normally
requires a change to your economic status
of a country or even a business, but luckily,
some are coming to the table now especially
when they can find other way to make money
off of climate change. For example, Samsung
has found a way to actually start selling
TVs with climate change as a feature. If you
look here, one of the features that they are
asking, whether it's important to you, is
whether the temperature in New York at 88
degrees Celsius is a desirable feature. So
enough on the background. Now onto the geospatial
tools. So the basic overview of what I'd like
to talk about is the problem of trying to
get complex spatial temporal model data into
a format that can be visualized in the virtual
world for KML. But to get to that path, it
requires something in between; a Geospatial
Data System that can actually manage the ingestion,
storage, how to filter that data, how to format
it correctly and finally, to deliver it as
a KML file to the client. So I'm going to
go over the components of that system. But
first, I'm going to start with the visualization
client, or virtual globe, or Google Earth.
And the main benefits of visualization climate--or
client like this is that it allows you to
see your data in a geospatial and temporal
context. You can upload data of your own via
KML language. Google Earth itself offers a
rich set of reference imagery that can be
used for putting your data into context. And
the KML language allows you to talk to external
servers for loading up additional KML as users
navigate around the globe and space. And also
there is some temporal functionality, but
unfortunately, it's a bit limited compared
to the spatial functionality of the KML language
and Google Earth. Here is a table that kind
of gives an overview of the things that you
can and can't to do at current with KML language.
And in terms of attributing objects, there's
the ability to put attributes of both space
and time unto your objects so you can view
around and see in both space and time. The
Google extensions to KML allow you to tour
both in space and time. But after this, the
functionality kind of breaks down and there's
less support for time especially in terms
of navigation. You have the ability to navigate
in time but only data that you have loaded
up in the past. You can't navigate beyond
the bounds of the data that you have loaded.
Also, it doesn't allow you to request data
from external servers via network links that
give you an understanding of what time you
are actually interested in looking at. And
then also regions and overlays; two powerful
tools for managing large amounts of spatial
data don't quite add the equivalent in the
temporal domains. You can't overlay or originate
in terms of time and attributes. So since
Christmas is coming up, I thought I'd like
to put in my wish list for what would be nice
to see in the KML language and in Google Earth
in the future. Most of the time, Google Earth
is used to, what I'd call, just kind of points
on the map. And this is valuable of course.
It actually gives you a kind of a spatial
context for where your data is located. But
KML itself is a very rich language and many
of the features of it are underutilized by
the--most of the KML files are out there,
whether it's 90%, or 95%, or 99%. We don't
make much use of the advanced stages of KML.
So in order to do that, you can use the KML
Authoring library to actually give you access
to efficiently writing some of the more complex
elements of KML language. And up here, given
the example of using a libkml which is a C++
library that can be used to programmatically
create KML documents. That's a C++ library
that has interfaces in Python and Java that
allow you to create KML efficiently. This
is the--here's an example of using libkml
with the Python interface to create a simple
place mark, but it's not really Python. I
think you are more familiar with that language.
So what we've done at [INDISTINCT] is create
a [INDISTINCT] for the libkml language called
pylibkml that gives you a more Pythonic way
of describing how to create a place mark or
any other KML feature that exist there. So
now, onto the components of the geospatial
data system. The first one I want to talk
about is the spatial database. And what we
use is the PostgreSQL open source relational
database modified with the addition of geospatial
libraries like GEOS and Proj 4 that allow
you to do 2G--2D geometry manipulations and
rejections. The result of this is the open
source spatial database called PostGIS which
has been pretty revolutionary in terms of
what it allows users to do with their spatial
data. Example of what you can use PostgreSQL
for is answering questions like this; at database
level, you can say, "Where has clear clip--clearcut
logging occurred within 20 meters of a stream
or a river?" And the SQL statement at the
bottom shows an example of that. In addition
to having spatial data that's stored in the
database that has the ability to run geospatial
operators like intersections, buffers, a lot
of the more common geospatial commands that
you might have found in like a desktop GIS.
We can do that very efficiently at the database
level. We also--another part of the data system
that is needed is a Web framework; something
that automates the task that--for setting
up a website that allows you to connect to
a database and efficiently create Web pages
or other HTTP delivered content. And so [INDISTINCT]
we use Django, a Python based framework. And
once again, it's modified with a number of
geospatial library, GEOS, Proj, and GDAL,
for manipulating vector and raster data. And
the result of that is a project, an extension
of Django, called GeoDjango. It's quite flexible
because Python is somewhat of a [INDISTINCT]
language and anything that--a lot of scientific
tools will all have some type of Python interface
that can allow you to connect to GeoDjango.
Example of how GeoDjango is typically used
is to create HTML pages with maps embed. So
here's an example of the Represent page for
New York City which allows users to declare
where they live by street address and it looks
up counsel members at various levels that
are representatives of yourself. And you can
actually monitor what they are doing on a
daily basis. So that's a typical use of GeoDjango,
but it's not just HTML pages that it can create.
It can create any type of format. It can be
communicated with HTTP. In this case, we're
going to be using it to create KML. So putting
it all together, GeoDjango is kind of the
core framework that we're customizing here.
We designed it so we can store our data in
PostGIS spatial data. And then we'll take
scientific model data, run it through Python
libraries, SciPy and Rpy, which understand
a wide variety of different data formats into
GeoDjango and then into PostGIS for storage
and then to--when we're accessing it, we want
to format in another representation. So we'll
hook up GeoDjango to pylibkml and libkml,
and the result is you can output KML documents.
So to see them in action, here is just a recording
of--starting up a Django run server or a Django
Web server, and you can ask--access content
that's within Django through a browser or
anything that speaks HTTP. And so here, I'm
loading up a certain KML file which is "Particles
That Are Trapped the Atmosphere." And you
can either load them up in a browser or you
can actually make network links within Google
Earth that can talk to the Web server itself,
retrieving KML from the Web server. So in
this case, it's going to load up particles
for a particular time, simulated particles
that were released in the atmosphere. And
as you see in the upper left, there is a log
of the GeoDjango file going on there and you're
starting to see hits against the Web server.
And back in Google Earth, you can start to
see the data that's being load--loaded as
it talks to the Web server and requests KML
content. And from there, you can start navigating
in Google Earth the content. So this next
example is more back to the carbon story.
And this is a series of towers that NOM runs
in the United States that sample a long time
series of very accurate carbon dioxide measurements.
And what is this? It's being shown here the
visualization is using KML and a combination
of model and scaling tags in order to show
a time series of measured CO2 concentrations
at a particular tower. When it's blue, it's
above the background concentration of CO2,
and when it's green, it's below. But in order
to make use of that data, you want to figure
out where that carbon dioxide in the air has
come from. So the next thing I'm going to
be showing here is the output from some particle
tracking simulations for particles that were
collected at the--or air masses that was collected
at the LEF tower. And we're going to do--type
of atmospheric model that tracks these particles
backward in time to see where they have been
over the last 10 days. So we're starting to
go a little bit farther backward in time.
You can see there's about--showing about 100
particles here. But typically, these are run
for hundreds to thousands of particles at
a time. And this is the tracks of where they've
been over the last 10 days. The symbology
I'm using there for the tracks is gray when
the particles are above the atmospheric boundary
layer or somewhat isolated from the surface
and green when they're below the atmospheric
boundary layer or near the surface and can
exchange carbon dioxide with the land surface
and the air. So it's picking up the information
where it's green. Google Earth, a powerful
use of it is that you can actually see kind
of the forest and the trees at the same time.
So right now, we're zooming into the details
of these particles clicking on one of the
particles that has been attributed with the
information from the STILT Atmospheric Model.
And this can show scientists a lot of details
about the model outputs, once again, providing
a very detailed spatial and temporal context
for the data that they might be using. So
particles are nice and they're actually kind
of fun to track around and watch, but the
real information that we're trying to get
out of the particles is how sensitive are
these carbon dioxide measurements at the towers?
How sensitive are they to processes that are
going on the Earth's surface? So this next
animation is going to be of sensitivity maps
showing the sensitivity of one particular
tower to processes that are going on--in--on
the Earth's surface and this is based on the
results of those particle tracks and where
they happened to be near the Earth's surface.
So this is showing a constantly changing map
of where that tower in Wisconsin, the LEF
tower, is sensitive to. Right now, there's
particles that are starting to simulate it
that are coming down from Canada, and you'll
see that they start to line up with the sensitivity
map. I should say that for the map, the heights
of the blocks that are being animated here
is proportional to how sensitive the tower
is to processes that are going on in that
region based on the particle tracker. You
can put several of these together to start
getting the idea of what parts of the United
States are being represented by these towers
and the concentrations that they're sampling.
So here's three towers; the WKT Tower in Texas,
LEF Tower in Wisconsin, the AMT Tower in Maine.
And you can see quite often the sensitivity
of these two towers overlaps and that's just
because of the way the wind is blowing. It's
like it's carrying information along--pass
two towers at the same time. Since you have
it in Google Earth, you can actually overlay
it by other data sets. This is a land covered
map that actually was one of the products
that one of our other speakers presented on
today. But it gives you an idea of what land
covers maybe contributing to carbon release
or uptake at different regions. So to give
a little summary of what I've been showing
and what the next steps are, first, I was
talking about Concentration Measurements.
And these are kind of an animation of a piece
of data that is fixed in 3D space and variable
on time. So, you have X, Y, Z, and the time
of capture of the particles, and also showing
Sensitivity Maps. And these are 3D maps in
X and Y, but they also have two times associated
on; the time of flux or the exchange of carbon
dioxide between the land surface and the atmosphere,
and also the time of capture that is happening
at the tower. Sometime it takes, you know,
up to 10 days for those to be connected due
to the--the way that the particles are [INDISTINCT]
by the wind. And for the animations I was
showing, I was actually showing the first
three variables of the time of the flux rather
than the time of capture although the time
of capture is interesting to some of the scientist
that actually work on the towers themselves
and are trying to interpret their data. But
really, what we're after is Flux Estimates
of carbon dioxide and how it's being exchanged
between the land and ocean surfaces and the
atmosphere. And so in order to get from what
I've shown so far to the Flux Estimates, scientist
do something called an Inverse Modeling, because
what we're looking at in terms of concentration
is the result of the process but we're actually
wanting to know what the actual source of
that is; the flux of the emissions. So with
Inverse Modeling, you can combine the Concentration
Measurements and Auxiliary Datasets together,
and then relate them to the fluxes by that
mapping of the sensitivity that we have, and
it gives you a probabilistic estimate of what
is coming out or what is happening in terms
of carbon dioxide flux. And that also has
two spatial dimensions and one temporal dimension.
Most interesting though is that this is not
a--just a single estimate but it's a probabilistic
estimate. So in addition to the Flux Estimates,
you have some measure of the errors or how
errors are correlated in space; the Estimation
Covariance measures. In this case, we have
four spatial dimensions representing two pairs
of locations and also element of time. So
that's kind of one of the next steps is trying
to use Google Earth to go forth and go beyond
3D space in time but actually start doing
visualizations of these higher dimensional
datasets. We have some pretty good ideas about
how the styling can be used to do so. So a
lot of this work I've been presenting, the
datasets have come from other research groups
that has spent a lot of time generating the
Atmospheric Transport Models and the use of
the--and aggregating that data together into
sensitivity maps for the carbon cycle science.
So I do want to acknowledge Professor Anna
Michalak, the University of Michigan, and
the PUORG Research Group that provided several
of the climate datasets that I've shown in
the visualizations today, and also Professor
John Lin at the University of Waterloo in
Canada who is the creator of the STILT Atmospheric
Transport Model. In addition, this work relies
heavily on many Open Source Projects. So I'd
like to thank those projects, their contributors,
and their benevolent dictators. I've met a
few of these along the way and more often
by e-mail than in person. But I'd really like
to call out, in particular, Justin Bronn.
Justin was studying to be a lawyer at the
time in law school when he wrote the extension
to Django that's called GeoDjango which has
been pretty revolutionary for the type of
data that we work with. So he has successfully
passed the bar after creating the GeoDjango.
And finally, I just want to say that there
is--this is just one type of spatial and temporal
data, and there is almost an unlimited amount
that is out there in terms of complex, space,
and time data that are being generated in
models in the scientific community. And so
I think it's a real challenge and opportunity
to put those data in a form that's more readily
accessible by the general public decision
makers and such. And Google Earth is a great
tool for trying to communicate this type of
spatial and temporal data. I've also put up
their links to project--an open source project
in the repository that you can download if
you want to see how the GeoDjango works that
I've described in this talk, and also a link
to the pylibkml project. And that's it. Thank
you.
>> All right. Well, any questions for Tyler?
>> Just a classic example of "A picture's
worth a thousand words," because I actually
understood more of inverse modeling from your
talk than I have in reading. Nice try there.
>> ERICKSON: Well, that's great. And we're--we're
going to do more...